nice one helen
is he gonna be funny in one of these
oh no no no these are like low-level
fights you're gonna be fighting
up there
welcome back everyone is charlie
shangshin the legend of the ten rings is
out i know you have lots of abomination
questions so this will be my video all
about what's going on with the
abomination during the shangshi movie
the director and the producer said this
is just meant to be a teaser for big
things that are happening for him in the
future marvel phase 4 so we'll break it
all down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there's a bunch of really big
stuff coming up and obviously careful
for spoilers for the shangshi movie if
you have not seen it yet because we'll
be talking about some really spoilery
stuff but when shanxi and katie go to
macau to find his sister mistakenly
thinking that she contacted him with the
postcard of the great protector dragon
john john explains this whole big
operation it's very reminiscent of the
operation that sharon carter builds as
the power broker inside madrid poor in
fact when they first released the
trailer and we saw some of these scenes
out of context a lot of people
mistakenly thought that it was meant to
be madrapore we find out that his sister
shah ling ran away from home at the age
of 16 and came to macau to set up this
fighting ring operation she's turned it
into this whole big thing it's obviously
meant to foreshadow the turn where she
takes over the 10 rings organization in
the post-credits scene they passed a
bunch of low-level fights including the
extremist soldier from iron man 3
fighting one of the former liberated
black widows from the black widow movie
sort of foreshadowing the trevor reveal
just another connection to iron man 3
the last big marvel movie to invoke the
mandarin even though the way they
explain it in this movie wen woo never
called himself the mandarin and they
turned the name into an even bigger joke
this movie is also being released right
after the black widow movie but the
black widows that natasha and yelena
bolova freed with red guardian and
molina happened years ago during 2018
right before the events of avengers
infinity war so you have to remember the
time jump this is happening in 2023. so
if that black widow had not been snapped
she would have been participating in
this underground fighting scene for
years same thing for the extremist
soldier the events of iron man 3 took
place back in 2013 10 years ago but then
they reveal wong finding the abomination
in the main ring like the big fight
mortal kombat style for the big money
that is an awful lot of sandwich money
that wong just won himself yes it's a
super cool cameo scene but the bigger
twist is that as they fight it actually
seems like wong is almost coaching the
abomination he's even kind of pulling
his punches so to speak metaphorically
then literally like he pulls the
abomination's punch through a portal so
that he knocks himself out as they fight
he says you want to know how it feels
i'm going to show you how it feels the
abomination isn't quite as powerful as
the hulk almost as powerful as the hulk
so as you saw in all the trailers he is
able to smash one of wong's magical
shields like that's how strong he is
wong seems really pissed off like he was
expecting him to pull his punches a
little bit so that's why he pulls this
trick on the abomination causing him to
punch himself and knock himself out but
he calls abomination by his real name
emil blonsky and even though you can't
tell that much just from watching the
movie tim roth did come back to do some
vocalization for the character during
the movie he was also at the movie
premiere so that is him making all those
noises in those grunts when they're
fighting and they modeled tim roth's
face for motion capture for the
abomination here even though he looks a
little bit different i've talked about
this in previous videos already but the
reason why the abomination looks
different now is they just made him more
comic book accurate if you're not a big
comic book reader or just been a long
time since you've read those original
incredible hulk comic books this is
exactly what the abomination looks like
in the comics the coloring of his skin
down to the fins on his head his pointed
teeth within the context of the mcu
though it's most likely that his gamma
mutation just continued to evolve and
change his body over time at a slower
rate like the initial dose of gamma and
serum that he was given during
incredible hulk turned him into this
during that movie but that was back in
2008 cut to 13 years later and his body
just continued to change until it looks
like this the real reason why they
changed him though was because back when
they made the original incredible hulk
movie they were just playing it safe
trying not to make too many
weird-looking characters the director
claimed he didn't like the finns now
that they've done rocket and groot two
super popular marvel characters shown
that people are totally down for talking
raccoons and talking trees the super
weird stuff often winds up being the
most popular stuff so kevin feige says
that nowadays they feel safer doing the
super weird stuff like alligator loki
was not something that they would have
tried back during marvel phase one and
now in present day he's one of the
biggest fan favorite loki variants
superior loki but they take this wong
abomination thing even further like he
almost seems like he's bros with the
abomination like they're mates and
they've been hanging out for a while now
then they have this joke about a bunch
of dudes having to drag him out of the
ring because he's so big and heavy after
their fight and in the locker room just
a moment later wong asks him how his jaw
is like how you doing buddy it opens up
a portal to a special high-tech facility
where there's a special containment cell
with a bunch of lasers designed to hold
them it looks very reminiscent of the
one that nick fury built to contain the
hulk in the first avengers movie he
tells him that he needs to learn to
control his punches like they practice
confirming that wong has been doing this
with abomination for a good long while
now and as i explained the timeline of
the movie this takes place around the
time falcon and winter soldiers
happening but before spider-man far from
home and spider-man no way home so
several months after avengers end game
so everyone's asking why has wang been
working with the abomination it just
seems like a super weird thing to do
clearly something more is going on here
than wong just wanting to earn some more
sandwich money i think it's pretty clear
from the look of the facility that he
takes him back to that this is supposed
to be the raft because that's where he
was taken after the events of the
incredible hulk according to kevin feige
like they just kept him there all the
way through avengers infinity war the
snap the blip in avengers end game so
whatever he's been doing this whole time
they always at least take him back to
the raft even though he's only in the
movie for a hot second the producers
said that this is only the beginning for
the abomination in marvel phase four so
i think we're probably all in agreement
that this is all meant to be set up for
a val scene similar to the black widow
post credit scene where they explained
that he's either been working for val
for a long time already like the way
elena bulova was when we saw her show up
orval is going to show up and recruit
him when he comes back in the she-hulk
series because that is the next place
they've confirmed abomination is coming
back according to kevin feige mark
ruffalo's bruce banner and his hulk are
also coming back for that too for
she-hulk's origin story and that's also
probably why banner showed up during the
post-credits scene as well because when
you're picking who's going to show up in
avengers post credit scene how do you
pick usually you want to tease something
that's happening really soon and a lot
of what happens in the post-credits
scene is foreshadowing for future
avengers 5 stuff which we won't see for
a long time in for instance the reason
captain marvel showed up in that
post-credits scene even though captain
marvel 2 the marvels movie with the
multiple versions of captain marvel
isn't gonna happen for a good long while
is because daniel crenton the director
of the shangshi movie had worked with
brie larson a lot in the past and they
were friends and he just said oh you
know whatever the post credit scene
winds up being i would love to work with
brie larson again so if you're wondering
why they did it avengers zoom call like
they did during avengers end game that's
why they did it that way because they
had to explain how captain marvel could
be there yet still be on the other side
of the galaxy increased squirrel space
and they also said that they picked the
characters that were going to be in the
post-credits scene at the last minute
like that was literally the last thing
that they filmed for the movie during
reshoots so kevin feige and marvel
wanting to tease what's happening next
in she-hulk is the reason why bruce
banner was in that post-credits scene
specifically the whole thing with
abomination during she-hulk though is
that the series is actually being billed
as a half-hour legal comedy type of show
even though i don't think that it's
going to be a comedy straight up like
they're playing up the idea that she's a
lawyer for superheroes in the marvel
universe so that's why it's going to be
a nine episode series because it's going
to be closer to the episode length of
juan division but even though she's a
lawyer her normal gamma form is always
closer to being more like professor
hulk's gamma form like she rarely went
full incredible hulk so she spends most
of her time as an eight-foot tall green
lawyer who's super strong but also has
all of her mental capacity and
intelligence is jennifer walters and
because of the lawyer part of it all
they kind of tease that they're gonna be
doing different cameos in different
episodes like different cases in
different episodes and they'll use that
to cameo different marvel characters
abomination might be one of her cases
and that's why he's back for the series
but also as part of that they'll weave
in the val thunderbolts and dark
avengers of it all also i hope that they
tease a big hulk vs abomination rematch
but we'll see because of the whole
banner of it all like he's turned back
into banner now from professor hulk i
know there are a ton of questions about
that too you have to remember that
banner can control his gamma form and
even though he had an agreement with the
hulk like that's why they became
professor hulk because the hulk wanted
to be free but banner also wanted to be
in control as well i don't think they
plan on killing him off or anything like
that anytime soon i think part of the
reason why he's banner here is one
because they didn't want to spend the
extra money with the extra couple
million dollars it would cost to do him
as motion capture is a full version of
the hulk because even though they do
have a big budget for the movie that is
super expensive and it's way easier to
have him just look as banner and show up
with the sling and i think that
budgetary consideration also factors
into the way that they're going to use
him during the she-hulk series like yes
he will hulk out at some point during
the she-hulk series but he's probably
going to be banner for a lot of that too
just because it's way cheaper to have
him walk around as banner but the whole
vibe of abomination during the shangshi
movie is that they're trying to give him
more of an anti-hero arc in the mcu
instead of a straight-up villain the way
they ended with his character in the
incredible hulk film it's also a
possible early theory that they pay off
some of that thunderbolt's dark avengers
stuff during captain america 4 because
clearly all the val stuff and all these
different movies and disney plus series
is building up to something bigger like
when are we actually going to see
abomination running around with john
walker us agent baron zemo yelena bulova
all the other marvel anti-heroes that
she'll theoretically put on that team in
fact julia louis dreyfus was also seen
recently getting ready to film near
atlanta where they're filming black
panther too so a lot of people are
theorizing that she's going to show up
during black panther 2 to recruit
another villain from that movie you can
let me know in the comments who you
think that might wind up being it also
because we know from the black widow
post-credits scene that yell and a
bolova will be a big part of the hawkeye
series we're going to see those episodes
later this year val also might show up
again during the hawkeye series if you
remember the big disney plus event that
happened last year where they released
all those trailers there were a whole
bunch of trailers that they dumped
they're gonna be doing the exact same
thing later this year in november so
when i do videos for all those brand new
trailers for all the upcoming disney
plus series they'll probably give us
release dates for some of that stuff i'm
working on a new video for avengers 5
and all the stuff that they set up with
that in the post credit scene obviously
everyone's still wondering about where
that signal is broadcasting to from
inside the 10 rings and what's going on
with them that should post in the next
couple of days make sure you have alerts
enabled so you don't miss that my full
marvel what if episode 5 video will also
post wednesday just like normal everyone
click here for my shengshi post credit
scene video and click here for my full
shangxi breakdown video with easter eggs
for the entire movie thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe and i'll
see you in the next video
[Music]
[Applause]